you know it's funny because you work on
the same a lot of people right right you
worked
over yeah so i just came from rehearsal
your staff was nice enough to offer me a
limousine pick up and drop off
which uh i almost took them up on just
to see the expression on the driver's
face when he dropped me off 120 yards
after he picked me up it was a long
enough limousine you could get in the
back and then climb to the front
and get out
uh you guys i've met so many of the cast
members uh on the show everyone seems
very nice you must be having a good time
there we do it's an absolute love fest
we're a real family over there we have a
great time
you have so many uh celebrity cameos too
we have yeah who you have a favorite
celebrity cameo so so far someone that
you just delighted you uh oh we're
delighted yeah uh
george takai was on from star trek
am i saying that right now no he's very
particular about it too it's taken yeah
yeah he gets really uptight about it
he's like you have to come to k yeah i
was nervous about it so he won't be back
what's he what what did you like so much
about george takei i was fascinated with
how grandiose he is and it's almost like
he's doing an impersonation of himself
it's almost shakespearean how he's just
oh my and just very he was over at the
uh the craft service table where we eat
one one one day and i think there were
like swordfish fajitas or something and
just the way he puts things he said oh
it's it's fruity at bovine
[Laughter]
i like this man
i like this guy i've heard that many
times about me
how andy
about a year before i had done a play in
new york that required me to be nude and
he had mentioned that he had had seen it
and that he had uh that he had he came
back three times to see it
it was fantastic
and of course i was very flattered and a
little frightened yeah after that i'm
gonna go back over by the swordfish
fajitas yeah now let's talk about uh
there was so i i've i've talked a number
of times to your co-star jim parsons on
the show very nice guy and uh jim um
had the honor of of winning the emmy uh
last time around uh and and you guys i
don't know if it was at all awkward
because you were in the same
category yes and so he's a friend you
love the guy but you're there at the
emmys and then he wins how did you feel
at that point well you know i mean it's
not a competition i was thrilled for him
i'm
obviously a fan of his
work and fond of him personally so i was
really ecstatic for him well terrific we
have a uh i think a clip of at that
moment
let's take a look
and the emmy goes to
jim parsons the big bang theory how
about that
this is jim's second emmy and third
nomination
[Applause]
damn it absolute [ __ ]
for nothing
[Applause]
what are you so happy about for so many
reasons taxi